So were undeniable.
They were,
they were experiencing like very vividly the same things.
And the government's obviously obsessed with this and isn't worried about,
but here's the problem.
Here's the problem that that term,
the government,
are you talking about the post office?
No,
I'm not talking like police officers.
Are you talking about the fire?
The Fire Department ruling Techno Tronic who are these people?
But I think the government is a shitty term.
I know who they are.
Okay,
but that,
that term,
the problem with that term is it lumps you into like,
you know that Mel Gibson movie conspiracy theory was a wacky dude was driving a
cab,
have believed in fucking tin foil hat type shows.
He'd been tortured.
Yes,
exactly.
You've been departmentalized.
Yes.
But,
but that kind of stuff,
when you say the government is doing it,
like who is doing this?
Who's working on these experience?
We don't have to say names.
No,
no.
Like is it the,
obviously maybe you want to say the gutter.
No,
I'll tell you.
It's a broad brush.
You,
you're right.
It's dumb to say the government and the big question is who runs things?
That's a smart question.
That's the thing is they,
when everybody says they don't want you to know,
do you remember that fucking guy who is ripping people off like weight loss
secrets that they don't want you to know Kevin to Trudeau and they put them in
jail for that.
He's in jail right now cause he won't give up the money cause he's got a pile of
cash somewhere and he said he would do that.
They was the,
I think they said they would give them time off is a con man.
I've met him a few times,
very manipulative but I think he has a right to Shay healthcare cures or natural
periods.
I don't want you to know about,
there are some,
but the point is they don't.
Look,
I,
I have some love in my heart for Kevin Trudeau because he started the
international pool tour.
It was a,
he was putting a lot of money into professional.
Cool.
Here's the deal.
The oxycontin company,
the documents came out.
Shit.
We're going to totally addict people and then we're going to sell him drugs to
get off of it.
Yes.
That's pure fricking either.
So lock your ass up and then we'll get to Kevin Trudeau lighter.
I agree with you.
And I'm not even defending catheter though,
cause I met with evergreen for your time.
I know all about him and it was like he was 100% about him and a one way free of
straight.
Well I didn't get that experience with him with me and him just talked about
pool.
I was doing some stuff with him when he was first starting the pool tour.
I came to a couple of his events,
but he,
that day,
this thing is like,
you always have a good way of asking questions instead of saying who runs it.
All right.
You wait till I do the cliche the government and then you correct me.
What I'm doing is playing devil's advocate and I'm also looking at it from the
perspective of hours.
They're still,
Eddie's come,
let's do another hour and get out of here.
Okay.
Let's let Johnny will become a two.
No,
no,
not yet.
Do you want him to come at two instead of one 30?
Whenever you want.
I'm gonna text him.
Right.
Anyways,
let me,
let me try to be clear.
Joe,
I'm having a good time with you.
I just want you to know we've tried to be clear.
I can't say all of this on here.
Okay.
And I'm going to leave it at that.
But um,
I'm on record 20 years ago before anybody else was talking about the clockwork
elves and other global listening to her in touch with these entities and things.
Only because,
and I don't want to get,
I'm not in the CIA.
The CIA's bigger than Coca Cola.
It's like bigger than Walmart.
I'd never been an intelligence agency.
I've ever been a part of any of this stuff.
But I had family that was advanced Darpa research projects that I don't know all
the details about.
And,
um,
when I was a kid,
my dad told me about some of it not knowing how to be a talk show host layer,
but like when the deputy director of the CIA,
he did have a tooth pulled to cater to my dad.
Okay.
Show.
Then I was like the doctor to,
you know,
these guys.
And I remember sitting around the kitchen table and I'm like seventies,
like Carol,
I can't tell you all about it,
but it's a classified program in Maryland and an underground base.
And uh,
they won't give me all the details,
but it's double.
The money I'm making now is international security.
But I think,
I think it's basically,
you know,
we're going to,
we're building cyborgs and we've got special forces that have volunteered if we
could infiltrate the Russians and get to codes and systems in,
I believe it's in planting,
but messages in their teeth.
And I,
and I also think it's,
I do implants,
I think it's a brain surgery program for microchips.
And so I'm hearing,
am I,
Carol's like,
David,
I'm sick of these people and you've already done so much for the government.
And look what they've already done to you and a met my,
my brother,
you're not going to be,
you know,
I want you out of this.
So this is like,
you know,
seven,
eight years old.
You're not hearing about the,
you're hearing about the cyborgs.
Okay.
So,
so that's the kind of stuff that I grew up seeing and you know,
Oh let's go get your uncle.
He's come off of [inaudible],
you know,
Army Day in an army uniform from Guatemala.
You know,
there's like armed guys with machine guns.
I mean,
I don't know.
Okay.
And I,
and I don't need to know.
Okay.
The point is,
is that's what I grew up,
you know,
the type of stuff I saw and my dad never told me about all this stuff when I was
older till it was like 12 years ago and I was finishing in game blueprint for
global and enslavement.
That's free still online and it's all about the world government and now the
cell phones watching you and everything's,
everything's proven in it.
It didn't come true.
It was already true.
And the plan for one world government and don't have kids and all that and
attack on the family and we were going to go to a ballet recital for like my
three year old daughter.
She's like 14 now or whatever and they sit out for like an hour and watch the
end of the film three our film and my mom goes,
tape it.
That's not true.
He goes,
yes,
it's all true.
When I was in junior in high school,
they recruited me into the program there and they brought us in and they said
the Nazis were wrong because they were only targeting certain groups.
We're going to talk to everybody and it's a planetary breakaway and world
government and blah,
blah,
blah.
There's a nuclear reactor under ut and all this other stuff,
which later when research is actually true,
it's not even hidden,
but the point is,
it's not that my dad was even that special.
They get,
my dad was like
score like the six smartest in Texas and they got a group of less than 10 kids
and they brought him in as juniors in high school and shed.
We're going to do all this.
Like they recruited them cause I wanted to be a NASA.
That's why we're in the natural shirt.
So when it gets in here,
cause because Eddie's right,
NASA is a big secret group.
It's the other side of the breakaway government.
There's the CIA breakaway government in 1947 and there's Kennedy setting up NASA
in 1961 so they're two different competing breakaway governments.
And those are the real governments in the U S..